Hi, my name is "Xiaoyo Wang"
Partner and CastBox CEO
Two years ago, the company's initial model was designed as a personal software developer
I did not expect this rapid growth in the podcast market
CastBox has benefited from Google technologies and services to evolve steadily
Now the company has provided content that is preferred by more than 7 million users
In less than two years, the team has made up 40 people, not one
Since the launch of our application, improvements have not stopped and their assessments have become impressive
Shortly after CastBox was launched, a letter of thanks was sent to us from Russia
Because our rich audio content has helped her learn about the world
The company was also nominated to win as a prominent Google Play award winner
2017 to gain a broad reputation
My name is "Xiaochong He", a partner in CastBox and its IT director
My job is to use technology to get the best content
TensorFlow provides a multi-algorithm model
And made the process of submitting content proposals more precise
And when a user logs on to CastBox
Can identify content that suits their interests
The CastBox application then combines listening data and user behavior
To provide the best content suggestions to the user
This is the exact connection between the user and the content he likes
Enable CastBox to reach retention rate for second day 70%
The average daily use of the application is more than one and a half hours
Also enabled instant app on Android
You can use the CastBox application without installing it on your devices
This has strongly contributed to enhancing users' access to content
My name is "Chippin Lee"
A partner in CastBox and its marketing director
Interacting with creators is a key to CastBox success
It allows us to deliver content based on a sound system
We provide two monthly payment models based on Google's subscriptions
The first model is Pay Per Channel and the second is a separate subscription based on functionality
Flexible subscription options contribute
In providing services to important and ordinary users
As well as giving us more information about their needs
Our success depends much on Google technology
More than 80% of our users use Android
We always strive to provide more features to our users
Provide better content suggestions and enhance the listener experience